yeah hello and welcome to this video
covering Game three of the World
Championship match can be held in New
York between defending champion magnus
carlsen and SEGA kyle canyon first two
games were really a bit of a snooze fest
to be perfectly honest that was not
particularly great but if got in a
really good game number three yeah in
fact people coined as an epic struggle
and I can't agree and I mean in in
Europe um with the time difference this
game lasted until close to three in the
morning and i was watching till three in
the morning because it was really
completely captivating to watch and see
how it will turn out at the end so let's
have a look at this game the only thing
I have to say is it's extremely complex
and a long game and I didn't have all
that much time this video is already out
pretty late because of my other
obligations um so I would have liked to
look a little a little bit deeper before
making the video but I also don't want
to delay this there's a game for plate
just in a couple of hours so game three
cars is wide and we see e4 no Trump
offski again no big surprise the Trump
probably was more of a one-off so we got
the Berlin defense which I mean this is
a 12 game match and if this match would
have been yeah I have a society that
would be bad sir and someone would bet
and we have noble in defense and this
match will probably get pretty good solo
odds on that much money that would
happen so we have the first berlin and
carlton goes for castles he mostly plays
d3 in this position and yeah opt for the
slow maneuvering game um castles takes
an hour rupee one and a principled way
to do this is of course to go for the
famous burn in war ending
decide but it seems that currently am
yeah white is not getting anywhere there
and yeah so rookie won by cars this new
past reputation of being extremely solid
rocky so um and down is often they are
seen as a way to be to play for an
advantage completely without any risk so
what gets the spawn back and now the
bishop on b5 was a tech service draws
all the way to f1 pink sand castles we
already see that the e file is opened up
and we have a completely symmetrical
bone structure deform we should have six
Lucas attacked and now we come to the
first interesting moment of this game as
cards now does not play the perfectly
normal-looking rookie won but plays
rookie too that's a pretty
strange-looking move yet what is the
loop doing only two however it has a
couple of interesting points this move
on it seems was yeah not on Kai Atkins
yeah preparation list as we see if we
jump one move further it spent more than
20 minutes on the reply actually
somewhat surprising I mean it's not like
this is the super hot move that
everybody knows about but if you look in
the database you find high-level games
like 20 22 there are four games in total
in my database and one has been played
between chasm Joe November cumin two
players that are in the top 100 in Casa
journal is a very well-respected
theoretician so it's a little bit
surprising that this was actually a
surprise like a complete surprise it
seems and what is the point of this via
talking move um well it has a couple of
ideas and i'm pretty sure i don't
understand them all and one thing is
what exactly should black play now in
most cases after rook e1 which is some
move to compare it with
black plays rupee eight and here a
popular idea is to play with Bishop f4
and this kind of this kind of move like
a bishop inform this kind of move is
actually more effective or that was the
wrong button I'm sorry that kind of move
is actually more effective with the rook
here as if black takes you can actually
recapture with the bishop and not have
the Queen on a one after a capture yeah
even this would be a little bit better
in comparison and having the Queen on
Yvonne it's a very small detail but we
are working on those are those small
details are currently what the world
class players are working with so this
is one little idea the other idea we'll
see in the game kayaking place them
would be six hinting at this idea after
which council immediately replied Ruby
one so he basically lost the move here
by whoops whoops in two steps so he has
given black an additional tempo here
there must be six it is however
questionable and this is so helpful for
example blacks most usual set up in this
kind of position is with night coming to
f5 and then d5 and c6 in this structure
you probably don't want to move B 6
plate as it weakens the c6 pawn and with
it the whole Queen side black rather
prefers such a pawn chain which has no
clear weakness meeting bb7 and
theoretically but tough together but the
c6 square nephew imagine that and I can
just put it on the poor Nia just to see
what I'm talking about if we would get
an obstruction like that this is a
vulnerable porn if you imagine a white
knights may be coming up to e5 this
would actually attack the pond and the
structure like be 76 65 is more
difficult to attack so those little
things are what makes the move route it
to quite cunning so Ruby one what did
kya can play played rook e8 and now we
see Bishop f4 you had the move p6 is
extra and here there are some some
little traps that our ever four players
on that level easy to see for example if
black tries to win a pond he is failing
due to this double attack something oops
like in this for Bishop 86 is losing for
black it's easy to spot at least for
those guys yeah in the game he took but
of course didn't take on d4 but played
Queen to e7 and black I think has to be
quite alert here and move like Bishop d7
which looks perfectly normal i think is
questionable because this kind of
structure is pretty bad black is never
never getting rid of those weakened
bonds and some trades now actually would
mean disaster and a position like that
the white would manage to trade of light
squared Bishop for example he would just
win probably not getting a fantastic
square on d5 and yeah easy ideas against
the week porn so this is a bad
structures like I a complete Queen to e7
being ready to take him um with the
Queen 93 to develop and manage their 93
to develop there should be seven and now
we come to trade and a four we are
trying some things you're sorry some
things on the a file is one idea and the
other ideas to potentially take on d6 so
if black does not react to this let's
say a place completely non move yep then
white has a five and this is it doing
something as also the idea Bishop takes
on d6 and then nine
b5 black played a 6 which is the normal
reply to such an idea to be ready to
answer a fi with b5 which would actually
am cannot not help at all instead cousin
played g3 yeah what is this position by
the way um houses assess I think it's is
equal it's just equal I think I I can
defend it precisely after this rookie to
move which certainly am yeah it seems
took him by surprise um but currently
not much is going on of course precision
is important yeah it's not like both
sides can play any move and be okay but
objectively speaking I think black has
equalized g5 attacking this dispersion
and the bishop doesn't really have
anything great to go yeah I mean if you
let's say you return your you're sitting
there in night at five ideas one what is
the bishop doing here and so again
neither five is a bit of a problem so
just the capture and Bishop g2 so that
blacks bishop pair is some is taken off
the board ya tinkin and now we get this
material distribution a black Bishop and
black rook against white Bishop a white
knight and white rook and these endgame
types are among the most complicated
that you can have that difficult to
handle and in many cases require
extremely precise calculation because
the coordination of the pieces it just
just gives many possibilities to to play
um and I think we will probably see more
of this and in this match those kind of
complex endings we had the same material
distribution in Game one with kazem
having rook at night against them
rugen bishop and i think kya a plate
this fine now we played at five that
takes important squares IAM especially
for and you have 95 for centralization
king of 793 tf6 i think this is all
quite understandable now to see form
yeah the night is looking at this Bishop
asking a question do you want to move or
not cocky decided to move the bishop um
this is I think an understandable
decision for sure but it has to be
mentioned that in rook endings often the
activity of the roofs is more important
than the pawn structure that means that
completely something that groupie eight
probably wasn't bad at all if white now
decides to caption it doesn't feel like
um this is giving wide anything at all
black a threatening rookie to which is
something that white has to yeah watch
out form if he decides to cover it like
with the simple moves like this black
will probably enter here and the
position like that is just equal is it
equal by not sciencey home but i'm
currently I'm kind of wondering rook a
three years irritatingly I ok we can
probably do the same and cover
everything yeah it's difficult for why
do to do to get any any progress going
here he cannot easily move the king or
do anything active it was an option he
doesn't it did not need to retreat it
necessarily but it is a good it is a
good move I mean don't get me wrong it
just important in there in end games
just with rook rook endings if you have
an active route you can often compensate
a week pawns as the the ruckus is often
just a
like a yeah a contest of two looks
taking pawns and sometimes readers met
have the doubled or not and so rookie
one then why does a bit quicker on the
e-file and rook da discovers the deep
olive just if 95 happens m-f form now by
cars and now we get to this phase of the
game where it is a continuous task here
from both sides to answer questions and
it it is more difficult for black I
think yeah it is equal probably with
good play with perfect play but blacks
the question that white can ask black
like do you want to do this or do you
want to do that they're a little bit
more difficult to answer for black and
this these kind of positions is where
cars and really scores a tremendous
search when is the amount of points and
yeah kayaking has to answer the question
what to do with this pawn then take a
lot to take in the game he decided to
capture I think this is correct if G
boys played in in general yeah this is
mmm very difficult decision of course
but it's I think here long-term he
certainly are feared that even night
pops are 23 that the king is permanently
tied to this pawn this is the thing the
good bishop yeah I cannot protect I mean
if you look at this from a color complex
perspective the pawns on light squares
and the bishops on a dark square this
good Bishop cannot protect this pawn
black here would much much prefer to
have a light squared Bishop if he could
let's say bring it to have seven and
potentially enter here and cover this
born here f5 could be a potential
weakness for the rest of the game night
can come here white might go h3 open up
the H file I don't know what
if you like a good decision to me so I
feel like taking is probably better f5
is vulnerable but is just one porn on
all the pawns and f4 is a so awesome or
isn't some kind of target for counter
play as well I think I a keener a place
is really well in played b5 kicking the
night takes and 292 III yeah the night
clearly belong to you three looking at
this 95 was possible but you want to
attack the pause c6 covering this and
now the black rook was going for counter
play certainly I'm very logical yeah
look g one that's obvious them what
wants to attack this pawn and now again
a big question yeah what should black do
yeah you can play age six you can play
Bishop h6 if you want to prevent route
to g5 or you can play the move that
kayak and play you played rook a tune
and it seems that Bishop h6 that's at
least what the computers give bishop age
six is a good decision yeah it just
covers the this crucial square and it
does not seem that white can do much
progress do I have some lines in let me
check that's actually kind of comparable
to what we will see one move later I
mean why can try something like this
yeah Brooke g3 to h3 but an important
thing is that here's a counter play yeah
you can attack here and then move like I
mean okay this is clock oops yeah so
probably here in our group A two and
black has come to play note that this f4
point as i said is also something that
black dis attack um he's probably okay
him in the game
can play rook to a two and after b3 now
again there was this question what to do
and I think the next move was probably
not the best after that he starts to
struggle note that they had decent
amount of time but it is not easy to
figure this out he played the movie 5
which is probably wrong as after that he
is in slight stature on Bishop age six
again it seems to be the right decision
after which it seems difficult for white
to prove all that much yeah white can
try different things they can't ride if
I for example I try to gain gain a bit
of space but then what do I have here
yeah but i can try this maneuver you
need targets yeah you need targets and
it seems that um a black is ok here you
can analyze that of course a lot depends
later where which also can be analyzed
in great detail but I think there are
limits to what you can do in the video
this whole game is actually pretty
rewarding to analyze I'm fairly certain
I look at this um for for quite a while
but I had to to other things and you can
look much deeper and he played this news
and the problem was said after Luke g8
now again it's a little bit tricky yet
to go here the bishop was hanging yeah
you cannot take him if you do this wyd
remains material of yeah we pick you
will pick up the porn so King f7 broken
back and now this is aiming and after
she takes Knight and five the deep on is
a problem it's hanging a black cannot
easily cover it how to do it if you want
to do this with bishop to to c5 you have
to reckon with King you form and this is
just not looking at the porn but also
stopping any d 3 moves I mean being
effective maybe 3 now the King can take
in the game we jettison the pawn
immediately to make sure that at least
White has splintered porns there so
therefore isolated pawns now but what
has one upon a great result here for
cousin who didn't have all that much
like 10 12 moves ago I mean all that
much is an exaggeration yeah he didn't
have anything so those small imprecision
Slyke the c5 move here led to white
having an advantage is it enough that
white should win um it's difficult to
say I don't think it is it should be a
win but black has to defend extremely
extremely precisely to put the draw and
in fact I think the general level of the
plane from here on was exceptionally
high really exceptionally high look a
one the look is coming around to get for
counterplay think I get to get some
cloudy play and causal provokes the move
before that makes lots of sense so that
this pawn is on a dark square can
potentially be attacked later by the
night air this is Bishop now as a more
passive outlook yeah rook g fiber that
makes sense activates the look it can go
here to d5 to be five attack all those
pawns and just as active on the
fifth-ranked um I think next couple of
moves and make perfect sense would be
one and now look at five check yeah
Brooke h5 was also possible but I think
look at five check was fine chap one
keeps an advantage here no no matter
what cat here check and black was
basically a pushing the King upward but
now returns back to
the weekend we can pawn and there are in
fact a couple of lines that you could
could analyze but Gannett hazard limits
here own cousin played rock g5 an
interesting alternative was the move
rugby 8 this is I think given a stronger
by by the engines and it did it looks it
looks strong and really does king of
seven is not so great because of Knight
f3 black can now not check here because
of the fork and he actually threatens
both moves Knight e5 NR g5 and yeah that
looks uncomfortable and something like
claw do this it's not clear that white
wins this but I think he has he has
gained the last couple of who's so King
to e7 is probably tougher and then why
can you turn here basically allowing
night f5 and potentially bring the King
around I think that looked a little bit
more promising than rookie five but it's
very difficult to say without a really
really deep analysis constant with what
she played also post lots of technical
problems King when Jeff's to have seven
yeah King King d8 doesn't really help
all that much what do you play though
look III prolly cover this and go here
tf7 is also a bit more biological I
think rock t5 an interesting decision
now after takes which was played by
kayak in 77 Luke takes 27 we have this
trade of the deep horns the general
black drawing strategy is of course to
get rid of the pawns yeah what black is
aiming for ultimately it's probably to
draw with the bare root against look at
night this is a pretty common scenario
from from an end game like that black
tries to get rid of the pawns and maybe
ultimately sacrifice the bishop so that
the final
on is eliminated we will see some of
that that it is later yeah Kingdom he
ate was played this is correct yeah the
king should should help him kingi it
doesn't really do all that much and
white returned here we have to see that
White's position is very nicely
coordinated and the night discovering
the pawn that's very nice and rook and
King are also very active still I think
it's probably a draw with perfect play
but it's not fun we know however that
kayaking isn't extremely extremely
precise defender so this is right up is
elia trying to defend such position and
succeeding actually in most cases we'll
see how it turned out in the game yeah
so black played rook h3 attacking the h
pawn and yeah now White has a choice you
can try various things I think Magnus it
shows rupee 5 check was good this is
also approved by the engine you can of
course try other things here moves like
knight c6 for example night e 6 now if
you look at 96 for example that has this
thread and we have to see that after the
check hand clap King f6 and I've got a
it's nice and warm trick and this for
example is completely had completely
lost ya one reason is that this pawn was
provoked to be before this is a target
and gap how it's black supposed to stop
both this keep to keep the air be poor
as impossible and taking is wrong why
have I am like a black should probably
do something something like that give me
five and what does mine under the same
five Brooke h2 where there are plots on
some issues here now you can clock not
be sure to win the science gets Buddhism
what do I have in pledge to end okay and
it actually does not work I should
attach that question marks there yeah
Rukia Keaney five years to probably play
Bishop e7 to hold on um it's it's very
difficult to say what what my twin and
might not and what you can do is and
some of those endings if you have an
extremely strong computer we are like 40
core machine or something it might be
able to calculate this all the way
through this is actually the case a
little bit later where computers can see
until the end nowadays yeah rook h3
Carson plate this which i think is a
very human decision the rook is
defending this you keep all the pawn
some kind of kind of coverage and you
try to harmonize the position a little
more next couple of moves um yeah rook
take Luke um I saw it Bishop g7 first
it's just an awfully long game and a
mess of nodes knight c6 yeah you cannot
if you allow the trade ya then it's
probably an immediate draw and they look
ending you cannot win the rookie is very
active here so if you allow the capture
it is probably end of end of it let's
see six is correct yeah maybe intending
um night to the eighth check or
sometimes Knight e5 check in to go to
Luke ending when you get a pony only
five but 98 is the main idea yeah okay i
can cancel ook h5 check which also think
is correct yeah if black takes this by
the way then we see the point
check has to go back thank you go here
cat yeah you get into other problems and
here you have 896 and yeah it loses
loses stuff why does son keep it at a
pawn in all cases like here you would
probably drop this pawn but you will
keep the airport um he couldn't do that
so the check was played also correct
kinky form also made sense I think it's
so difficult to judge the different
different details now rook c5 good move
taking now is no good yeah we don't want
to trade even more after this oops sorry
h5 k and you should f8 black gets this
with a check in fact okay in this case
in order the check but where the tempo
move let's say and now black ISM is
getting nearer yeah he's go would of
trading off all pawns clap yeah night da
check King g6 and I to e6 and the night
is coming around clap h5 sort of counter
play clap and the root gets activated
again now you cannot take your time to
check but be sure f6 was played by
kayaking all this is absolutely fine I
mean we have to see this way with the
engines nowadays this is almost we can
almost mathematically um approve almost
what what is best yeah they have steps
still some limits but and I mean for now
close to 20 moves they play this
perfectly I mean this is really great
yeah Carlton is keeping
some can some advantage she's his
probing here and there and kayaking
finds all the right defensive moves
there there are really many ways to
stumble an H form this move was viewed
with much suspicion during the live
commentary that I that have that I
watched at the time by Peter Svidler and
Grand Master Eric Hanson they also have
to agree it looked it looked a little
bit strange to me to put some porn on a
dark square ultimately it proved to be
not that bad I mean at least this is
what the what term but the current
status of the analysis there is but
still it looks a bit strange to put this
year h3 makes sense you have fixed upon
on the dark square um yeah and now we
approach the absolutely critical clap
party of this game tonight is coming
around and it's heading towards c4 not a
bad square for this piece yeah note that
this is so this is just nothing yeah
because here black has those counterplay
pawns those targets for coming to play
and the f porn is not not dangerous at
the moment it's easily blocked so the
night was coming around to see for rook
to d1 a good movie for here so there's
really not much left here f5 check king
went back that's you for an hour looking
for check this is also correct there was
also bishops III but this is a good
decision yeah the status quo is not yet
changed all that much Bishop g5 during
the live broadcast the commentators
correctly I mean I completely agree
assume that this was a mistake but
engines now prove that there is
this is actually ok it makes her however
it's difficult for black little bit see
k arrow key for Clark check kingi for
and yeah the bishop is hanging on g5
what what do you do and Kathy now gives
a check on 1g3 which yeah again was
viewed with suspicion but it still seems
to be okay if you can believe the
computer probably you can it probably
was easier here to play Bishop f6 in
this position but okay okay again this
is this is ok if you if you continue to
play correctly now and yeah it seems
that here kf8 is the move that draws I
mean this is pure computer chess king of
eight is drawing hmm why exactly is said
drawing and why not I don't know what he
did Jeff and I'm what do me a favor
should have six for example is it ought
to be played Bishop e7 no Bishop f6 here
it seems that what do I have fun yeah
night 96 clock gives white excellent
winning chances here the H point is a
sort of counter play but I think this is
better than their other comparable
situations I mean maybe you get a get a
full result here full a clear assessment
if you give an end in a very long time
or if you have super high and hardware
it's really difficult to analyze for for
a human player I think this looks very
critical for black however why can you f
8 apparently draws it's hard to say I
mean I saw that in the chat space let's
check that someone
head lettuce engine run to depth 70 or
something and it says that this is a
draw I'll give up I'll give up a line
bye-bye the engine is this this is what
I could could figure out its this if you
yeah take here now cat this is one one
way of getting a porn back and I mean I
kind of understand that this could be a
draw but how do you assess that in an in
a real game also king of eight is
extremely counterintuitive I played this
one and we have to note that we all move
64 so both players in that I think the
times they were fairly realistic or are
fairly realistic 15 minutes left for
kayaking twenty-something 444 Carlson
and after Bishop e7 the position is
probably it's probably lost if i'm not
mistaken now trap check king up yeah the
other moves didn't help either yeah
where else i mean you step into into
into all kinds of pins and and yeah okay
here this is also a clock tree bad yeah
so King King to have six hot check and
back here um instead let me check what's
that an option to take immediately
probably not no it was up to sorry
rookie six now this is the thing white
wants to play 95 96 and yeah this is a
huge problem for black the only thing
that you can try is take on h3 taking on
b3 is are probably opposing less
problems something that you do this is
is winning forward it's something that
you have to really think about for a
moment yeah why is this why is this
actually winning if
black chicks here kingi forwards the
spawn and white will manage to
coordinate and pick up both and what
else look here then why it probably will
take I didn't look at this probably will
take here yeah that should work should
be able to pick up this pawn and then
win with the H con so the best chance
was to take on H 395 check kingi 7a you
have to give it up like that there's no
alternative clock check and the
dangerous is quite clear white might run
out of run out of pawns this is what
blacks ideas trade down all the pawns or
get the H porn running yeah here it
seems that rookie aids was fairly
straightforward way to win however yeah
if the computer tells you that it's all
nice and good but those guys they have
played for six hours there and they have
to really really be precise ER and I
mean 220 to pay play perfectly in such
position is this basically impossible
and rook e8 it seems was a in comparison
if you look at the other lines
relatively simpler winning this is the
idea yeah you come around with the night
here to hold the b3 porn it's a it's a
fort and then get to this what was my
line here look h1 check and now good
minus p2 note how nicely this is
co-ordinated and yeah after age three
King each form age two white will pick
up this pawn with head yeah
Roxy to it should be it should be a win
let's left to be kind of alert down but
I think it's a win um he played 96th I
think that also wins but as I'm sorry
that doesn't win I'm sorry it doesn't
it's really confusing because my notes
are nice and it doesn't wait but the way
that kayaking now can save themselves is
absolutely absolutely fantastic let now
can draw up with just one particular
movement this is Luke to see three the
funny thing is this line Clarence yes
check calm and it looks like white is
just a pizza but drooped III if you if
you are no a bit of chess history or
just want to want to look at something
funny you can compare this game this
kind of situation here with the game
played in the two thousand World
Championship match between Kramnik and
Kasparov mmm I'm not quite sure of the
game number should have looked that up
it was an ending where crumley can an
extra piece but somehow couldn't win the
night was so weirdly placed that you
couldn't win and this is a really weird
situation as well yeah it looks like why
does a piss-up and quite is a piece of
but you absolutely cannot coordinate
this position in a way that you keep the
b3 bond it's just not possible the night
here is attacked and um yeah what is why
it's supposed to do here you are you
actually a risk losing and if you check
you don't get to a stable position it's
really funny this is just it's just
weird yet like this like is approaching
here you will not be able to coordinate
sometimes knives are pretty weird pieces
say they sometimes they have no squares
it's amazing and this position is a draw
why does a piece up but cannot win I
mean kayaking did not play this we have
to see is down down to six minutes here
right and it's not easy running or and
he took on f5 and after that Carlton can
win again with the rookie won or with
what he did now by now be in the
territory where the computers can give
us a clear valuation I think someone
posted that rookie one was made in 40 or
something crazy I know this is true Adam
it it might be Yahoo p1 seems to be good
now and that is some more convincing
than what he did the move that cars and
played also seems to win according to
the computer but it's more difficult to
do and yeah rookie one so how does that
continue the main basic ideas to play
the night back here and yeah for example
King our forum click the check here and
night if fire this is the second idea of
course the night is protecting this and
now with King Jafar the pawn should fall
yeah a position like you like this
should be relatively easy because the
night is such a and reliable defender
you will also win after Luke trade and
black can come around to take this then
you return you never lose this ball and
b3 so that was a waveform for Carl's to
win the game here he played Knight e5
immediately which also still wins look
aged one and now it's only one move rook
f7 check he played rugby seven yeah the
difference between all those boss is
really difficult to figure out with a
couple of minutes left and I think it's
actually um well it's difficult to see
that rook f7 would win necessarily
however to see that rook b7 doesn't work
as some yeah it's actually not that
difficult he probably just misjudged
something with the rook moves I probably
thought it didn't matter it's hard the
same I didn't watch the interviews and I
don't know what what those interviews
can can really yeah but what kind of
coherent talk like they could bring up
after seven hours of five the ROP seven
now Black is miraculously get into it
from rook a 1 we should look at and do
win him drive seven king us to move
let's say this is fairly logical looking
and if he goes here the White King comes
around I think yeah h3y a check and can
you pick this up yeah now look a one was
what's the move attacking the night and
there is the H porn white really I mean
he cannot do all that much now anymore
he and get checked on on b5 if you move
the naija then the h-bond will run and
this is the moment where you probably
spotlights where you lose with white and
some red some it's up cases this is the
moment where you kind of think think
again there don't lose with white hey I
checked clap took this with a check and
now despite being a piece down black is
quick enough the H porn is giving the
the counter play yeah not less so he
gave the check ID c 4 h 3 and now they
clap they
only one check and now they agreed to a
draw yeah after those two extremely
boring draws we have this big big
struggle yet 78 moves and I mean I now
made a video of more than 40 maybe 45
minutes and not quite sure I don't have
a time on and I didn't even scratch the
surface so and I didn't want to do and I
couldn't do it to our video it's it's an
extremely complicated ending this and
done I mean there were chances miss but
still an extremely high quality game I
think with all those some extremely
precise calculations that have be done
and I can assure you I I only am touch
touch the surface that you can look at
this not deeper mean spin and hasn't had
plenty of lines and down in their
broadcast um it's really interesting to
look at this in more detail probably you
will also find some sources online where
you can look at this in PGN format not
in video and then look a little bit
yourself I think that's probably going
to be very interesting experience
analyzing such a complicated ending yeah
I think with this game the the matches
no way officially started an interesting
would be to consider the psychological
impact of this game most people set
during the broadcast on Twitter and so
on that if kayaking manages to save this
game it will be huge psychological boost
for him and maybe yes yeah I mean it's
certainly better than losing the game
that so thats it's clear but on the
other hand i also think that um me calm
can he's probably not happy with the
game yes but when he made lots of
pressure and he got him got him on the
ropes which is also good to see that you
are able to outplay the other guy he
can't you that before but it's good to
being able to see that you can do it in
this
then that's currently currently I'm
going on so am i am not sure i mean it
is certainly rather good for ki can then
for garden but i'm not sure this has a
huge a huge impact comes also usually
psychologically quite stable and i think
if he had a good a good match
preparation he I mean psychologically
you should be ready to for such an event
because kayaking is known to be an
extremely good defender and the
likelihood that this happens in this
match that Carson would spoil spoil a
winning position because of extremely
tough defense or whatever was quite high
that this would happen at some point it
happened yet now I rather at the
beginning and in game three but in
general cousin certainly could not
expect to convert like every game so um
I think it's interesting to see what
what happens from a psychological point
of view um yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage of this game I feel I didn't
dig that deep but again there are there
limits of what you can do um ok guys
thanks for watching I'll be back with
game for coverage tomorrow bye bye